[Musique]
Joyeux Noël
et reviens vite hey patron tu connais le
concours de pâtisserie de Noël dont tu parles toujours
ha ha la famille royale de
Belgravia t'invite à participer à notre
concours de pâtisserie de Noël ok on
laisse tomber Noël est un moment magique  de
vous, j'aimerais juste avoir quelqu'un pour le
passer avec les souhaits de Noël qui se
sont réalisés Je suis vraiment désolé pas de problème
qui êtes-vous Oh Lady Margaret Delacorte
Duchesse Montanaro Stacy denoble Je pense que
nous étions destinés à nous rencontrer
Je suis  censé épouser le prince Edward le
jour de l'an mais je déteste être sous les
projecteurs Je veux savoir ce que
c'est que d'être une fille normale
Je veux changer de place avec le Je
changerai de place Je suis devenu toi et tu
deviens  moi sortir
seul être pendant deux jours personne ne remarquerait même que
Stacy le Nobel a un penchant comment ça
pende un peu ça correspond
je suppose à l'époque si tu le dis Oh
qui tu es Je suis là je suis déterminé à
dépenser autant  du temps ensemble comme nous pouvons
sur t  les prochains jours Oh fracassant tu
n'apportes jamais rien Je suppose que je suis un peu
nerveux avec le grand concours qui approche
c'est bien
assez aimé en fait Noël devrait
être une question de chance Je ne t'ai jamais vu aussi
sentimental peut-être que tu ne me connais
pas bien Je ne pensais pas que les choses
deviendraient si compliquées alors que faisons-nous
[Musique]
Je ne sais pas  sais si je peux tirer sur
tout ça d'accord
ouais je vais bien
toi